je suis là soit parce qu'elle est la
lumière et puis moi je suis rentré et de
la lumière il y en avait pour 7 buts
edge parti vendredi soir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avait pris des
allures de circuits moto on permet aux
gens d'un petit peu lâcher prise mais
toujours dedans dans un espèce de
journée on est tous des sportifs de
sports extrêmes
donc on cher à notre manière les risques
y a pas vraiment beaucoup de risques
parce que la vie ne va pas très vite et
tout ça donc on essaye de canaliser les
gens dans un bordel ambiance années 60
70 ou presque et la beach party c'est
simple un dress code du sport un concert
et une absence totale de sérieux que je
suis un prix nobel de débilité et entre
prix nobel on se comprend et on s'est
tous rejoint ici ce soir est super bonne
ambiance et voilà c'est gentillet et
c'est cool on va tarder roman
super il ya de l'ambiance de belles
images c'est top
1 1
à saint quentin en yvelines c'était la
huitième du teich partie mais la
première en ile de france près de 250
buteurs sont venus s'affronter des
pilotes qui n'ont pas froid aux yeux
mais mme allen ou encore dix ans
physique